et bien bonjour à tous et puis merci
d'être là si nombreux en effet en cette
période de vacances scolaires parisienne
particulièrement heureux de vous
rencontrer à nouveau avec avec guillaume
d'abord on va commencer par une bonne
nouvelle elles sont pas si évidente ici
présentes dans la presse c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour notre mouvement et je ne
peux pas m'empêcher évidemment de
commencer par celle là je voulais vous
donner des chiffres
les chiffres ce sont ceux des nouveaux
adhérents et des renouvellements qui ont
été saisi le 19 février 2016 pour vous
les donnez donc à ce jour nous avons 40
3764 adhérents à jour de cotisation
nouveaux adhérents ou donc
renouvellement
c'est à dire plus de 4000 par rapport à
l'an dernier puisque l'an dernier à la
même date
nous avions 39 1852 adhérents ce chiffre
est donc particulièrement important je
vous rappelle que nous avions terminé
sur un chiffre très prometteur en fin
2015 puisque nous étions à 238 1208
adhérents et que de faire quatre mille
adhérents de plus seulement en un mois
et demi et évidemment pour nous un signe
fort et qui nous permet d'être très
optimiste
évidemment pour aller au delà du chiffre
de l'année dernière
c'est un chiffre d'autant plus important
qu'il faut le souligner aucun autre
parti politique ne joue la transparence
comme nous le faisons nous mêmes
ces chiffres sont validées par huissier
nous attendons des autres mouvements
qu'ils en fassent de même nous attendons
leur engagement à ce sujet dans l'agenda
de notre parti je voulais vous annoncer
une prochaine convention aux journées du
travail
elle aura lieu le 9 mars elle portera
sur la fonction publique et la réforme
de l'état le 9 mars
et puis par ailleurs je le disais avec
guillaume pelletier notre plaisir de
vous retrouver et on vous trouve
d'ailleurs très courageux de venir à
chaque fois parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'on est appelée à vous dire souvent la
même chose
alors ça c'est pas notre faute c'est
juste la faute
j'allais dire bien entendu du
gouvernement actuel de la situation
actuelle c'est à dire que chaque semaine
chaque semaine depuis des mois
maintenant on peut avoir les mêmes mots
pour qualifier ce qui se passe dans
notre pays
ça pourrait être drôle c'est juste
dramatique
chaque semaine donc même scénario des
couacs gouvernementaux
je vais prendre le dernier en date qui
n'aura échappé à personne et pas avec
n'importe quel ministre puisque nous
avons monsieur ayrault et madame royal
sur un sujet qui devrait faire consensus
au sein du gouvernement
le référendum pour l'aéroport nous
voyons que pour les uns et pour les
autres les délais ne sont pas les mêmes
et nous voyons aussi que les frontières
de ce référendum ne sont pas les mêmes
suivant ciel sont au niveau du
département où au delà des départements
ce couac et j'allais dire l'illustration
habituel chaque semaine d'un cafouille
mans et d'un cafouillage lui exactement
au sein de ce gouvernement
ce gouvernement qui est à la peine pour
de nombreux sujets en tout cas
particulièrement sur ses projets de loi
après la loi macron qui a dû passer en
force avec le 49-3 après la loi sur le
code du travail dont on voit les
difficultés la loi elle conneries c'est
donc un nouveau feuilleton qui commence
et je ne parle pas évidemment de la
déchéance de nationalité à chaque fois
que le président hollande et que le
gouvernement met sur la table un sujet
on est persuadé on peut mettre sa main
au feu que derrière la contreverse est
immédiat elle est immédiat que non pas
avec l'opposition
ce qui serait normal c'est une
controverse qui existe au sein même du
gouvernement et au sein même de la
gauche est maintenant au sein même du
parti socialiste le parti
qui est quand même censé soutenir
prioritairement l'action du président
les déclarations qui évolue aussi
d'une semaine à l'autre de monsieur
cambadélis doivent quand même interpellé
plus d'un militant c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
on comprend aussi que face aux dernières
déclarations sur les primaires il y est
un malaise à gauche il y a un malaise
parce que on voit qu'on annonce des
primaires comme ça a larache dans une
interview peut-être en décembre
peut-être en janvier quand il y a
quelques semaines monsieur cambadélis et
qu'il en était pas question
avec quel candidat on ne sait pas
puisque mélenchon par exemple monsieur
mélenchon a dit qu'il n'y participerait
pas donc là aussi cafouillage quand
parallèlement de notre côté comme vous
le savez nos primaires sont actés
financer organiser avec des dates et un
calendrier très précis donc ce
cafouillage il existe à tous les niveaux
il faut aussi rappeler que françois
hollande si nous sommes dans cette
situation c'est parce qu'il a été élu
principalement sur des mensonges et je
voudrais revenir sur la phrase très
importante que nicolas sarkozy encore
redit lors de notre conseil national qui
sera pour nous notre feuille de route au
niveau des républicains c'est dire ce
que l'on va faire et faire ce que l'on
va dire ça n'est qu'en faisant cela que
le discrédit des partis politiques que
vous avez tous constatée dans cette
dernière étude parue ce week-end pourra
se retourner
ce discrédit qui fait que l'on annonce
quelque chose et que l'on fait l'
inverse c'est à dire exactement ce que
fait françois hollande depuis qu'il est
président donc c'est une cacophonie
anarchique dans son propre camp et c'est
une anarchie sociales dans le pays avec
particulièrement évidemment l'explosion
du chômage
alors il ya également récemment ce
projet
ce projet de loi elle conneries on l'a
vu avec de notre part la salutation sûr
des engagements qui peuvent être pris
mais nous sommes bien loin de savoir ce
que va donner ce projet de loi qui n'a
d'ailleurs toujours pas étaient déposés
en conseil des ministres et de voir de
quelle manière il va être éventuellement
détricoter et jeu quand je parlais de
feuilleton tout à l'heure je pense que
nous sommes partis pour un long moment
et il est clair pour nous que
l'hirondelle elle conneries n'annonce
pas le printemps
enfin je voudrais vous dire que nous
aurons avec guillaume l'occasion de
reparler de différents sujets qui ont eu
lieu dans la semaine mais pour l'instant
la parole va être sur l'actualité
internationale et particulièrement
européenne et guillaume prend le relais
merci brigitte oui après ton très bonne
analyse sur la politique nationale
compte tenu de mes compétences très
connu sur les grands sujets
internationaux depuis une trentaine
d'années je vais pouvoir faire une
analyse sur le break site sur la
situation à calais on sait combien nos
compatriotes et les européens sont
aujourd'hui très attentif à cette grande
question qu'est ce qui est en train de
se passer si on prend un peu de hauteur
et un peu de recul
sentant précisément après les terribles
souffrances à verdun à peine plus de dix
ans après le référendum sur le traité
constitutionnel en 2005
la grande question des rapports entre le
royaume uni et l'europe entre le royaume
uni et les autres nations européennes
tout ça devrait nous offrir
l'opportunité extraordinaire de refonder
l'europe tout le monde sur le continent
européen est attaché à la belle idée
d'europe on est plus fort à plusieurs on
a besoin de cette solidarité européenne
et on a besoin de transcender les
questions nationales dans un contexte de
mondialisation sur les questions
agricoles migratoire commercial est
évidemment que la réponse se doit d'être
européenne
mais force est de constater et un
certain nombre de peuples l'ont dit ces
dernières années le peuple français en
particulier en 2005
à travers la victoire du non que si
l'idéal européen et notre idéal à tous
nous avons pour objectif de refonder
l'europe et je voudrais profiter de la
grande question du bric site britannique
aujourd'hui pour redire qu'elle est là
l'atout de la famille des républicains
sur la question européenne
vous savez qu'en 2005 beaucoup ont voté
oui
beaucoup ont voté non le non l'a emporté
moi j'étais favorable à l'époque au nom
est très heureux de cette victoire du
non mais j'ai été très marqué dans les
années qui ont suivi par la capacité
incroyable inédite en tout cas pour ma
génération à travers la personnalité
politique de nicolas sarkozy la drogue
de retrouver enfin un homme d'état
capable de réconcilier la france du oui
et la france du non parce qu'il ne
faudrait pas oublier que cette france du
non qui l'a emporté en 2005 au fonds
attend depuis longtemps un oui un autre
à une autre comment on refonde l'europe
il l'incarné très concrètement dès 2008
en étant de l'avis de tous y compris de
ses oppositions un très bon président de
l'union européenne ce que ce soit sur
les questions internationales la crise
géorgienne des liens avec la russie mais
aussi sa capacité à réhabiliter la
politique au sens noble du terme
la politique qui doit toujours primer
sur l'économique sur les marchés sur les
banques et sur la technocratie nicolas
sarkozy fut le premier premier homme
d'état en france pour la génération qui
est la mienne en tout cas à réconcilier
cette double idée il nous faut une
europe solide forte mais il faut aussi
au sein de cette europe des nations dont
la souveraineté sur les sujets
essentiels soient respectés et entre un
nicolas sarkozy profondément européen et
qui à réconcilier le peuple français et
les peuples européens avec la belle-idée
d'europe d'un côté en incarnant ce
leadership incontestable et de l'autre
un françois hollande et l'ensemble de ce
gouvernement
totalement absents des questions
européennes
c'est l'allemagne sur les questions
économiques
qui mène la danse c'est l'allemagne qui
donne le ton sur les questions
migratoires
c'est le royaume uni qui donne les
questions le ton sur l'indispensable
renégociation des questions migratoires
des questions d'indépendance des
questions de souveraineté des questions
de répartition des pouvoirs entre la
commission de bruxelles et les
parlements nationaux
donc on voit bien que la france et c'est
la grande leçon de l'année 2015 2016 sur
les questions européennes
la france est aux abonnés absents et
françois hollande n'incarne en rien une
capacité à promouvoir à proposer
l'europe nouvelle
qu'attendent les peuples européens nous
nous souhaitons chez les républicains
que la question du bric site soit
l'occasion à ne pas rater d'une grande
réflexion d'une grande renégociation de
la politique européenne et nicolas
sarkozy avec la même constance et la
même cohérence depuis 2008 lorsqu'il
était président de la république
lorsqu'il était en campagne
présidentielle en 2012 tout le monde se
souvient de ce discours de villepinte
tant décriée à l'époque et si actuel
aujourd'hui puisque tout ce qu il
annoncé tout ce qu'ils avaient annoncé
porter sur les frontières sur schengen
sur la reconstruction et la refondation
européenne tout aujourd'hui est sur la
table et dans le grand débat il nous
faut donc profiter de ce grand débat
britannique
pour nous la france reprendre le le le
la locomotive sur les questions
européennes
quid des grandes questions d'intégration
sur les sujets de politique commerciale
de politiques agricoles passe au bric
site britannique nous on a eu un mise de
l'agriculture qui est rentré bredouille
bredouille de bruxelles la semaine
dernière
se vantant d'avoir juste obtenu quelques
heures d'écouté de la part des
commissaires européens sans le début
d'une seule solution pour nos
agriculteurs rien comme initiative de la
france
le grand lien si gaulliste et 6go lien
entre l'europe et la russie
tout le monde sait depuis longtemps et
nicolas sarkozy avait su le faire en
rétablissant ce lien fort entre vladimir
poutine et les dirigeants européens sur
la question du terrorisme sur la
question de la sécurité sur la question
de l'agriculture
la russie doit redevenir un partenaire
fort solide de l'union européenne aussi
bien sur les questions de coalition
internationale avec des pays arabes pour
éradiquer d'esch et l'état islamique en
syrie et en irak que sur les questions
agricoles les peler les agriculteurs
européens
même si ça n'est pas évidemment la seule
réponse alors angoisse savent combien
les sanctions économiques et l'embargo
russe pèse lourdement sur les
exportations françaises de produits
agricoles et agroalimentaires
donc tout ça pour vous dire que le la
capacité de la david cameron à défendre
les intérêts du royaume uni la capacité
des politiques britanniques à redonner
la parole au peuple pour que le peuple
soit souverain dans la vision et la
place qu'on aura le royaume uni au sein
de l'union européenne tout cela nous
semble sain mais on va pas regarder
uniquement le royaume uni débattre pour
lui même ou dans son rapport avec la
construction européenne nous nous
souhaitons et nous considérons que la
france redevienne une puissance forte
une puissance à la voix forte capable de
donner le tempo et d'imposer un vrai
débat européen et donc nous nicolas
sarkozy dans l'ensemble des ténors des
républicains à l'ensemble des
parlementaires des élus locaux
nous allons continuer tout au long de
l'année 2016 à proposer cette nouvelle
vision européenne qui je vous le
rappelle repose sur deux jambes
d'abord une volonté de trouver des
sujets importants
on pense à la politique commerciale
sujets sur lesquels l'europe plus
intégré plus forte doit parler on peut
prendre l'exemple de l'intégration
annoncée
de la chine au statut d'économie de
marché qui entraînerait des conséquences
terribles pour notre économie et pour
nos emplois selon des différents
rapports de la commission européenne là
c'est à l'europe unie et forte de parler
de s'engager pour défendre les intérêts
des peuples européens des entreprises
européennes des agriculteurs européens
là on a besoin d'intégration là on a
besoin d'unité
là on a besoin d'une europe solide et
forte et al'inverse sur un grand nombre
de thématiques
nous devons être en capacité comme
l'avait annoncé nicolas sarkozy de
rapatrier dans les nations de soustraire
à l'autorité des technocrates bruxellois
un certain nombre de compétences là où
nous considérons au nom du principe de
subsidiarité que les nations sont plus à
même est plus efficace dans le
traitement d'un certain nombre de
dossiers
donc voilà l'analyse nous parce que on
peut analyser très rapidement le break
site donné notre position enfin c'est un
débat qui regardent les britanniques et
on sent bien qu'entre au sein des
conservateurs au sein du labour aussi il
ya énormément de débats qui vont être
lancés dans les quatre prochains mois
ce doit être l'opportunité à ne pas
rater pour françois hollande et son
gouvernement de s'emparer de la question
de l'avenir de l'europe et la france ne
peut pas être une grande puissance sans
une europe forte et l'europe ne peut pas
redevenir puissante et forte sans une
france qui retrouverait toute son
énergie tout son rayonnement toute sa
puissance et toute sa capacité à porter
et incarner les débats voilà ce qu'on
voulait vous dire sur la sur les
questions intérieures et national et
puis sur un certain nombre de sujets
internationaux lors il ya calais mais
vous aurez peut-être des questions on
peut faire peut-être la transition avant
avant vos différentes questions
éventuelles sur calais on
on marche sur la tête et à force de
refuser de prendre des mesures
courageuses sur cette question là on
s'enferme dans des débats uniquement
symbolique il ya le ministère de la
parole qui peut être un carnet où hélas
par nos ministres
messieurs 15 9 valls et d'autres ou par
des stars de cinéma comme on l'a vu tout
au long du week end
mais ce n'est pas à travers le ministère
de la parole de l'image de du symbole
que nous allons régler en profondeur la
question de calais qui exaspère
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens pas
simplement dans le nord-pas-de-calais
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
les français ce alerte car là encore
cette question fait appel à la
al'impression de plus en plus
généralisée que le pouvoir n'a plus le
pouvoir que la politique quand elle est
abandonnée quand elle n'est plus incarné
quand elle n'est plus courageuse que la
politique ne décide plus sur la vie
quotidienne de nos concitoyens nous
avons nous des solutions que nous
portons depuis très longtemps sur la
question de calais comme xavier bertrand
nous demandons le démantèlement total de
la jungle de calais c'est clair et c'est
net
nous demandons même beaucoup plus c'est
de nous attaquer aux causes de ce
phénomène
la première des causes tout le monde le
sait c'est ce qui se passe en syrie et
en irak pardon
de se répéter mais enfin c'est quand
même une réalité nous y croyons tant
qu'il n'y aura pas de coalition
internationale entre l'europe la russie
l'iran les pays arabes nous n'arriverons
à rien sur cette question là il nous
faut éradiquer
l'état islamique là-bas en syrie et en
irak
premièrement deuxièmement il nous faut
totalement repenser la gestion des
migrants et des réfugiés nous proposons
l'ouverture de centres de réfugiés de
migrants à l'extérieur de l'union
européenne aux frontières de l'union
européenne pour soigner identifié qui
migrants qui réfugiés qui profite d'une
situation qui à linverse vie
véritablement la guerre il nous faut
avoir le courage d'expulser fermement
comme le prévoit le droit les déboutait
d'asile il nous faut avoir le courage de
dissoudre les associations qui encourage
la clandestinité le les flûtes sans
papiers il nous faut avoir le courage de
démanteler tous ces réseaux de passeurs
et de mafieux qui profitent de la
détresse et de la misère humaine
il nous faut enfin vous le savez bien ça
fait partie depuis quelques années de
notre projet de notre programme il nous
faut enfin repenser la question de la
frontière européenne est d'ailleurs la
question de la frontière
le premier homme politique à l'avoir
porté ces dernières années c'est nicolas
sarkozy à travers la volonté de repenser
schengen à travers la réhabilitation de
l'idée de frontière qui n'est pas un
gros mot
la frontière dans toutes les unions
commerciales du monde dans toutes les
grandes entités du monde en russie en
chine en amérique du sud aux états unis
la frontière est une idée est un
principe noble
il n'y a pas de raisons que seule
l'union européenne rejette ou méprise
l'idée de frontière nous souhaitons que
soient rétablies des frontières
européennes fortes et solides nous
souhaitons que soit alimenté beaucoup
plus efficacement avec un vrai budget
frontex
nous souhaitons la mise en place de
garde frontières et deux militaires aux
frontières de l'union européenne car
tant que les frontières de l'union
européenne
seront comme aujourd'hui une passoire
vous ne réglerez en rien la question ô
combien préoccupante des migrants voilà
ce qu'on voulait vous dire sur ces
questions nationales et internationales